a day at the beach in essex fish chips
and ice creams a new tax on sugar and
salt could have pushed up prices here
that now appears off the table though
after a leaked version of the
government's food strategy failed to
include it a missed opportunity
according to campaigners the prevalence
of these foods these deeply unhealthy
ultra processed foods is is not equally
spread across society some people cannot
afford cannot access fresh and healthy
foods and this is not the strategy that
addresses that it nods in the direction
of processed foods being an issue but it
doesn't set a reduction target that we
would need to see
the new junk food tax had been
recommended by leon food chain founder
henry dimbleby in his government
commissioned review so what do people
out in south end think i worked for the
nhs during the covert crisis and so many
people are in there with underlying
health issues and a lot of that is
caused by poor diets you should have the
right to
to buy what you want it's your choice
and not have to pay more for it i think
if you're going to really try and change
your behaviors you need to kind of push
it maybe at a higher price on
sustainable farming the strategy says
there'll be further work on land use
animal feed and emissions and worker
shortages it also suggests eating more
wild venison and seafood but there are
more gaps here no expansion to free
school meals and little on cutting meat
and dairy this paper is by its own
admission focused on longer term
measures and while many of henry
dimbleby's recommendations are adopted
there are few immediate policies to turn
aims into action with just a commitment
of further research to look at the link
between processed food and obesity and
no direct intervention
that's despite some evidence upping tax
can work the amount of sugar consumed
from soft drinks dropped after a new
levee was brought in four years ago but
extending this would be controversial
especially at a time of rising prices
not only is it suggesting that poorer
families ordinary folk can't look after
themselves but it's also going to be
dipping into their own pockets at the
time when there's a cost of living
crisis and so i think what the
government should be doing instead is
letting families making make their own
decisions when it comes to what they
consume and what they buy for themselves
labour say political problems for the
prime minister have led to a
watered-down strategy i think if
actually this had been produced a few
months ago it would have been a much
stronger policy but the prime minister
is no longer capable of leading his own
party let alone the country and of
course we're all losers as a consequence
of that so this is going to have to be
revisited it is astonishing that our
country doesn't have a proper food plan
a frequent jogger boris johnson said his
brush with covid made him determined to
help people lose weight and improve
their health but set against a tricky
political backdrop doing that may prove
more a marathon than a sprint rob powell
sky news in westminster